mark wreckless probably never imagined
that he would become the focus of a
media scrum yet the prospect of him
becoming the second Tory defector turned
you kept MP was big news
the nervous-looking candidate was
followed by a more confident party
leader and with good reason I declare
that mark John reckless has been elected
as the Member of Parliament for the
constituency of Rochester and strewed if
we can win here we can win across the
country if you vote you Kip you get you
Kip if you believe in freedom if you
believe in low taxes if you believe in
clean government if you believe in
localism if you believe in people power
if you believe that the world is bigger
than Europe if you believe in an
independent Britain then come with us
and we will give you back your country
it wasn't quite the majority that was
expected but it was a win leaving a
disappointed Conservative candidate
looking ahead to 2015
I'm gonna fight every day until May 2015
to return a conservative in pain in this
constituency they're packing up the
by-election is over and as predicted you
kept one perhaps by not that much but
look the media glare continues and I was
at the Tory Party conference when Mark
reckless first announced that he was
stepping down Tories were confident they
could win this see this was a bad night
for them but they look at labor and the
Lib Dems - and say they've had pretty
terrible nights as well for some
disappointing that I have missed out on
an opportunity to represent the area
about so much but I'm very proud with
the campaign that we've run here it's
been very positive
I've had a lot of support from the
shadow cabinet from the leader of our
party and we'll say from MPs and
volunteers from across the country
meanwhile this man headed off to
celebrate in the best way he knows how
I'm Gary pine as David Cameron said it
will be another notch for Nigel Farage
and he will then be seen drinking a pint
of ale he was absolutely right the
UKIP's celebrations are piling up
including this one in a local pub mr.
Faraj says critics dismiss previous UK
wins as protests or one-offs
but Rochester and strewed he says cannot
be ignored this is your victory
favourite when it comes to next year's
general election he argues all bets are
on a new score Astana Sky News